hi everyone so my talk is going to be a
bit of different style to eddies and
those who just saw that and Eddie was
talking very much around and some kind
of things that are quite close to
production and quite like stable things
my talk is more around the journey I
took over the last few months and
playing around with neural networks so I
work a list and I've been calling myself
a data scientist for I know for years
now probably um I've been playing around
with Edison with machine learning and
things for more like seven but I first
started playing with neural networks
very recently I decided to jump in
somewhere in the deep end so I played
with a couple of little classifier
networks and they decided to play with
metric learning which is a different
beast entirely so I thought I'd I
thought my talk today will be best
around discussing the nature of that
problem and the ways all the ways in
which I did it wrong I guess so i hope
it's beautiful for some some of you so
there's a couple of things to consider
here and there's two kind of concept
that I we need to consider and one is
the nature of finding of whatever find
which is pairs of products and so this
is from our site and what we have is
three different products here and that
our freedom through blue and pairs of
shoes I think actually the common
projects from the same that we've seen
the last set of slides and these are all
the same product and yet they appear as
different products on our site and
that's not ideal and what we'd like is
to collect those three things together
and show them as one thing and the size
of the problem is relatively large we
have of the order of well we have 100
million images are kind of lot 106
million images at last count we have
more than 10 million more than 30
million products in an ungrouped form
and we've managed to cook them down
quite a lot to more like 10 million but
should be dropping that further than
that list a lot of like super content
still remains we know something about
about all of our products we know who
their design we knew who the designer is
we know what type of product they are
but if you try to do a brute force
search on this is if you take a like
classification you can take a random
sample and ask people to label them and
you get a thousand labels and that's
great you get you know get fairly rough
spread your categories if we pick random
pairs where they share a designer
show category only one in a thousand
will be a match so brute force labeling
of this is really really expensive we
brew you know we brew false label
categories we can't brute force label
duplicates just too much money and this
is you this is a useful thing to do and
it's great for our users it's nice to
have one product in a feed what you got
to show when searching a single product
and then when they actually get to it
let people know where they can buy it
from from lot of different places it's
also very useful in more of a selfish
context so as a data scientist I'd like
to work with cleaner data and so if if
we can take all of these things and
combine them into one entity and say
this is just a lot of a lot more data
for the same entity and then we can
classify that entity in one go that's
really useful so help specification
recommendations is really is really
helpful when a user visits either of
these different products it's useful to
actually say they visited the same
product and to combine the information
from those it is very very helpful it's
also useful what kind of thing like
marketing an attribution and you know
that you know you don't have to try and
put different competing products that
you're putting out there and the people
you're trying to drag people to your
site you actually got one product out
there that's better so before I talk
about this I actually wanted to talk a
little about something that I think kind
of came up live in the questions before
and and that's to do with the kind of
perspective of having multiple images
for a product so at the top here you can
see kind of collection of images that
are you know fairly good images if you
look at any one of these it's fairly
easy to tell if you have a kind of pair
of these whether you're looking at the
same product or if they're different
products but if you take you take these
and I'd be quite hard push to tell if
these are you necessarily these two
these these the same with these
different and this is particularly
difficult for the nature of the way some
designers take photographs so if you
take some red converse and some blue
converse shoes what designers will often
do is they'll take lots of side shots of
the different colors they'll flip one on
them over and take a picture of the soul
and then use that for all the different
colors so if you do exact match you can
get a perfect image match across nine
colors 12 colors and it's perfect it's
definitely the same image so that
doesn't really help you very much so I'm
building somewhat on the work that I'll
quite a lot on the work that Eddie's
been doing and in particularly
representation work
he's been doing so I thought well let's
see if we can take advantage of that and
try and you know dress part of this
problem so we want to understand
something about getting perspective but
we don't want to have to go through the
you know the work to kind of a huge
amount of words do this we want to do it
in the simplest way we can so the first
thing we do is we train a neural net
with classification it's not a super
simple task unless somebody's really
done it for you which in my case that is
true but in general if you want a pre
trained neural network they're actually
fairly easy to get hold of there's quite
a lot of them a lot of them available
for fairly general purpose data sets and
so getting called a preacher network
isn't too bad then you know you want so
in my case I wanted to know about I
think you can maybe faintly see it's the
nature of watermarks on laptops and
projectors we've got Alex idea of a side
on shoe and say back a couple so what I
want is to label one image that's a side
on shot so something you can fairly easy
identify the product from and one label
that is not something like a soul or
kind of an end on shop issue so I one
label of each just as a starting point
you know if you want remodel you need to
have at least one label of each class as
opposed to start then I will train a
simple model and this is something
simple in the victim machine is going to
have a relatively small and parameters
compared to so in this case it takes in
a nine thousand dimensional
representation so it has a dozen
parameters or that order compared to a
neural network which has 16 million and
it's a simple model and having trained
this model on to labels you can then ask
it which of the remaining samples it
finds confusing so in this example
confusing really means the probability
that is one class or another is about
the same it's kind of equally likely
that it's anything so he doesn't know so
if you label this sample and you are
likely to get a label that's useful for
describing the partition in your feature
space and then repeat repeat this until
you're bored and for me bored was about
500 labels and I've got some friends do
some more and we got to maybe about
thousand labels that was that was it
felt sufficiently boring and then you
can see what you get so these are some
predictions
of pose on images that were never seen
like none of these products / seen on
the designers of these products were
seen by any were featured in any of the
labels and so we have one product per
row and the very left hand image is is
the most likely to be a side on image
for this product and then they work back
to the least likely so it's not perfect
but given its 500 labels and we have you
know six million products and in this
particular data set that my dentist at
I'm working with is all sneakers and so
this is only about a hundred thousand
products I think fifty thousand parts
were working with and but even so it's
doing a very nice job of neatly ordering
the images and not only does it does a
reasonable reasonable good job of
finding a good first image but it also
gives a fairly kind of consistent
progression to the remaining images now
if you just took more images and you try
to do this I think this would be a
fairly difficult task and so this is
what there's kind of a question of why
this works so we've seen some pictures a
little bit like this before you can see
that the islands this is using tease me
to take this high dimensional space and
then flatten it down to two dimensions
where distance distance in this in this
two dimensional space is similar to
distance in the high dimensional space
as you know so if we just zoom in on a
few areas one of these we find about
this natural representation here and
this is at a lower level than what
you've already is talk then I've thrown
away all the fully connected layers and
I'm at the end of all the convolutional
so it's a little bit more low level than
that and we find that pose is actually
quite natural clustering so it's not a
surprise that this space can be used to
pull out particular pose features and
the other thing is quite interesting is
to find that actually in any given image
and the types of shoes that are close
together within these regions are off
similar types so you get like athletic
sneakers kind of place together and you
get like plimsolls first together
anything with a white sole tends to kind
of end up nearby so there's quite a lot
of information in this space so uh huh
maybe this is maybe this representations
useful to look at the duplicates and you
know this is great but neural networks a
great support to machines are great but
maybe maybe I should put the neural
network because you win everything they
do seem to be fantastic so let's bill
one of those now you've seen the kind of
structure with her before and but I want
to talk about and
I'm at a lot of you here are pretty
familiar with classification networks
they were very very common and I know a
little about them but one thing I
learned about as part of this is there
is a you can have alternate types of
network structure that are quite
interesting so the structure i'm
interested in is a symmetric learning so
you can start with two images and you
can start with in that you can take your
network and then you can pass one of
your images through this network and get
a representation you can pass on the oil
that image to the representation and
pass them both into your loss function
and this is in somewhere now just what
we do the multi-image work but in this
case we're not going to go into average
pooling we're going to pass them into a
specific kind of loss function designed
to deal with this style of network and
then we can back propagate that one loss
through the whole network and it will
adjust the weights of the city of the
one single network in order to make the
not to be useful for what we're trying
to do and in particular we're going to
use contrasted loss I use contrast
applause so this is a loss function that
tries to take things that want to be
close to get that you say are the same
and bring them close together and things
that are far apart ringing further apart
so two fairly critical terms and we have
one term that activates if the sample is
a pair of things this experiment work so
if the pair is labeled as being the same
then it your cost is proportional to how
far apart they are if the pair is
different then the cost is proportional
to how close they are if they're closer
than some distance and but if they're
outside of some margin and typical
modulus point2 so if they're more than
point to a part in this space they don't
cost anything so we're not trying to
move things arbitrarily far away just
far enough to have a bit of space around
things and then we just take you know
combine these two terms and average them
much like things like log loss and those
kind of things you'll be familiar with
so how do I actually go about the
process of doing this well I read a
paper just good paper implemented the
network and I SAT and watched the Lost
decrease I don't know how many everyone
who's actually done this when you
actually start sprinting out the loss as
you work through it's strangely
satisfying and you can occupy quite a
lot of minutes of your day just just
watching the numbers go down and then
and then you look at the results and we
find out what that actually worked
and it kind of didn't kind of him over a
well um I got this message on or in
person little thought that's quite nice
that's quite exciting maybe that's
worked and then I look a bit close
during well the things that I mean
there's those trainers with trainers but
that's because they're all from a
designer that only sells trainers so of
course they're the same so you had this
problem where you can convince yourself
that looks great but we actually kept it
all detail you can hands not working
that well but the loss had gone down and
the accuracy had gone up so i was a bit
confused why this seemed have been
working my numerical measure look great
and you know i'm doing cross validation
and I'm hell out tests it's time you
know you're looking great but it turns
out that the key to where this was going
wrong the clue was was in this line here
and these are all just the same images
like this different shot to the report
and effectively there was too much noise
in our data so when I went back to our
catalog and we looked at individual
products what we found is that because
of some quirks of a shower spiders when
when a retailer moves a page for product
we potentially see the same thing and
then we merge them together so you get
the same image multiple times in a
product and so it's just noise it was
just duplicates and my model was
cheating so became an important step was
to go and clean up the data I took a
step back from the neural networks a
little bit here and I went to look at
something that we'd previously
considered for cleaning up the data
images which is P hash for those you
don't know and there's a perceptual
hashing is it has a kind of similar
analogy to like hashing cryptographic
hashing except that it has this nice
property that images that look the same
have are very likely to have the same
hash and images that look different very
likely to have a different a different
hash so it's kind of it's useful to find
things that have been like recompressed
or resize but still you want to kind of
step with the same but it's only
designed to have things that look like
exactly the same image so we can we can
find identical images and match them on
this basis and but it does have the
problem of having unacceptably high
false false positives and negatives and
really party high but one thing you can
actually do is because we have a
collection of images you can rely on the
fact that multiple images must match and
this is something we hadn't been doing
the past and I went to buy additional
data set and it turns out of our 10
million products is about a million
that we can just compress together on
the basis of they have enough
corroboration between the MP hashes
between images to know that they're good
this is great it means we can get a
better data set to do the training on
the other thing is there are cases where
there's not enough corroboration to know
that the whether or not what to know
whether or not you should combine these
things but all the images that are in
that state all those confusing images
you can just strip out the data set
because you've got enough images by
product this isn't too much of a problem
you still get a reasonable set to train
with so I did this so now how could a
nice clean data set and I went back over
to a mother and I trained it and I got
my loss and this isn't going down just
about setting they stay quite a while to
like code up and train as well like I'm
doing this in China which is a lovely
library but it's not like scikit-learn
like is quite a lot you have to do to
get this working so and you know you
were just damning the images take
several days so hey probably should take
my head parameters just throwing them
default is not a great idea and it's all
right you know this is this is a
valuable thing you need to go to ingest
mixture of things comes attentively and
try exporting the space a bit and I did
this and I spend a couple of weeks on
this and they're still not going down
just quite despairing and i should say
this was like a few weeks ago and I had
this talk so okay I mean the paper was
from 2005 right you know no networks
have moved on since then so so let's
read some more recent papers and is
these two papers are particularly good
they have a different approach and in
particular and they talk about triplet
triplet loss rather than pairwise loss
so contrastive losses I've got a pair
that's what you know imagine you're
working in 2d space and you have a big
inning over the big 3d space and you're
trying to kind of flatten it out to 2d
and what you're saying is I want to
pinch these two points i want to pinch
them together because they're the same
and i got these two points and I want to
move them apart because they're
different and you can do it any way you
like and because they're unrelated you
can kind of walk the space in some
unusual ways and it doesn't really
matter and as long if you have really
big mini batches when you do this then
this is kind of stable but if you work
with small mini batches then you can
kind of you can see how this can be a
little bit unusual whereas the triplet
loss is a little bit different
you take one anchor and you have to have
one thing that you know is the same one
thing that's different and so you need
to sort the space relative to an anchor
point so the principle sounds great
stripping more stable and so we shall go
with that and again we want to go was to
lick what's lost early edge occurs oh
actually something anytime here is part
of working with triple loss as well
there there's a little discussion around
and using curriculum learning so
particularly using what's called soft-
triplets and that's where you only
consider and triplets that are difficult
but not too difficult so they've got to
have gradients for both the positive and
negative cases but they can't be like
completely inverted and really like make
it really hard for the network because
that creates more instability so extra
complexity anyway so don't know these
code this up and watch the lost a case
and now you know look at the lobby
results so hey it's still not working
and it's okay it's okay i've got i still
got we can have to go well you know we
all know the unreasonable effectiveness
of data um and you know i'm still not
working on a particular huge data set
here cuz i'm trying to get this yeah
it's a few thousand by eight maybe
addition to throw more numbers at it i
need to mean a bigger network so so
let's unite us do that that doesn't work
either okay so i'm rather despairing at
this point yeah there's probably there's
probably something i don't know how i
approach it maybe there's a better way
of approaching how to how to kind of
train these networks so at this point i
took quite a big step backwards and i
thought well maybe the first thing I
should check is I can I can do a really
really simple case and just make sure
that actually this is all working so I
took you know quite a large quantity of
code and just like way and I went
rewrote from scratch and very very
simple and I want to products I've got a
few images from each but I want to
products and I want to project them into
a two dimensional space and one that I
can visualize on I can see what's going
on and just check this make some kind of
sense so what I mean it does something
but it's quite aggressive what it does
but it's kind of going the wrong way
this wasn't really ideal and I played
with the gradient you know they're
learning read the learning rates and
stuff but I mean this happens this
really happens whatever you're learning
rate you can eventually get your learn
mr. bone where it kind of doesn't do
this for a while and then it does this
anyway it's really annoying and I said I
at this point I've gone back to
contrastive loss because contrasted loss
is a lot easier to think about and
reason about so so yeah this wasn't so
great but I thought well let's just have
a little bit explore and it's especially
small problem that I actually started
working through the maths of this and
looking at it I'm only doing I'm doing
9,000 dimensions into two dimensions so
it's a single matrix transformation it's
a fairly simple thing to actually debug
and kind of work to us going on and so
into this and one of things I found
quite quickly is I can repeat the same
process but I can see the most extreme
gradients that I get at each stage and
it's fairly clear that having a gradient
of like 50 when your weight so like no
one ever knew your values might one it's
probably the problem so I implemented
gradient clipping this is quite a
commonly recommended thing and it turns
out this actually solved that problem so
this was like I kind of really nice
breakthrough where suddenly I've got a
small small problem the small network
and actually with my two samples I'm
able to get to a position where it does
actually learn something and I can see
it I can see what's supposed to happen I
can see the loss go down and there's
quite nicely the numbers go down but
I've had this before and it was like
I've know that I've seen this I think
I'm gonna go down it doesn't actually
tell me it's really working so I
actually decided that well I'm gonna go
two dimensions and I only got like seven
images so when I just look at them so
this is when you in random initialize
the network your images end up somewhere
in your 2d space and one of the things
you can do is simply look at what they
are update the network and look at where
they move and so you can watch them
watch the network learn and figure out
how to move them around and this is
quite nice and you can see that kind of
some of the quirks in our networks that
you don't get like nice kind of simple
smooth stuff you get these kind of they
kind of sit around for a while and they
kind of have big movements and and this
is quite consistent like I've done
cuddle all this since then there's all
the consistency that they don't they
don't kind of bet they don't learn
quickly and as earlier this kind of nice
exponential decay thing isn't quite what
happens in the kind of the state space
and you also see that at the end they
always and of oscillating like
they hang around this unless you start
decaying your learning rates this what
happens and that's where you tend to get
things like overfitting and stuff
happening so that was quite like for me
that was really nice that was a good
point like I've I've learned something
about the networks I've learned that
actually if I don't use gradient
clipping I might get away with it but
things that you know this is an unstable
problem and large gradients are about my
deal with this so I thought well okay
let's let's talk a bit more data in and
you know see how that goes uh-huh this
is this is even more this is even more
upsetting because like this definitely
worked and and actually this is this
doesn't always do this um it turns out
that it will either do this or it won't
do this and it depends on how which
samples you choose you chopper your data
like it's sample from the train yet but
I sample of random subset my training
data and some subsets are fine and some
of them are not and this is quite like
it just doesn't like some of my data
points like they know I got none in my
data like my data is all good i've gone
through blow today the numbers are all
fine it turns out that what happened a
bit more kind of digging and
investigating in this kind of still
fairly small problem and i found that
actually sometimes you get by chance
you've missed a duplicate and so you
have two images that are in fact
effectively right on top of each other
and so what you can go and do is just
say well I want things to be about point
two away from each other if they're more
than point 0 0 1 and well either they're
a true pair and they're so close
together they're never going to separate
or they're a full spare and that is a
bug in my data that is a problem with my
data and it needs cleaning out so you
can just strip these out and I did this
and that was great and the world was
happy again I know I've got nice lost
numbers I'm afraid I have got a nice
gift for you for the year for this one
but one of the things i found was uh I
was still kind of not doing exactly what
the the papers talk about like and yet
to find a paper that actually says you
should do metric learning and not use l2
normalization so what this specifically
means is normally if you like your say
or you're using 3d space to consider
everything so you have this nice big
kind of 3d representation of all of the
all of your images and you know the
simple thing is you just forget into
summer in the space and you just measure
how far apart they are
and all this says is you want to
constrain them to be on the surface of a
sphere so you don't want to be anywhere
in the space they have to be somewhere
on the unit sphere in this space and
then you missed the distances between
them just the same and this is commonly
referred to as a commonly kind of site
as a thing to do and it's what all three
of these papers and and many others as
well which I haven't cited here talk
about doing but I haven't found actually
any good justification but why you have
to do this but I thought well that's
quite interesting so I went back to my
network and I Chuck doing the LT
normalization and it's fairly simple is
just as just a step you do in the middle
and you can still back propagate through
this so it's fine and it's under
something weird it kind of means that
all the losses are smaller but they
hardly move and I spend quite a while
playing with this but I actually it came
to the conclusion and that while while
there's several papers that say this is
great and it sounds fantastic and you
know hey I should follow the literature
I actually concluded that if I don't
normalize this it works great for me so
that's what I'm going to do and I
concluded that while while reading
academic literature to understand the
problems is fantastic if there's no real
justification in literature as to why
this is great it's just a choice
somebody's made then you know what it
works it works and so this is a thing to
come back to for me but I concluded that
I'm quite happy to just take and take a
model that does work and use it even if
it isn't like what's cited most commonly
so the specifics are ended up using and
where I am now i should say is still
much of the progress and so this is the
network that I started with so this is
that this is effectively the early
layers of zeldathe net and then all the
subsequent layers are fully connected
and so I simply ignored those threw
those away and so all of our images are
passed through this to this point we
just literally do mean we do mean
subtraction but we don't know any other
whitening of our data and so the output
of this is a 6 x 6 x 256 kernels
representation and I just take and I pre
calculate that for all of our images and
then I can just use there's just vectors
that I can use to kind of build the
network on so the network I build on top
and is fully connected I use value and I
use the contrast of losses working quite
well
and a little more playing and I found
that actually putting in two layers it's
very nice it gives you more
non-linearity the mod scripted power and
I financially standard setup first
elastically effort momentum stochastic
gradient sent works really well so
assume everyone knows to castigate in
sentimental is very similar but it just
has a term that basically takes the last
gradient update and content and combines
that with the current step which helps
to stabilize things a little grin income
is great and I found a little bit of
weight decay again just helped a little
bit my next slide I was hoping to be
more impressive but the model still kind
of in the middle of training so this is
this is after about and I don't know
about 20 hours of training or a pretty
large number of our images and it's
quite a mess but what's quite reassuring
to me is that we are starting to get the
different poses are actually converging
so these are all the same shoe and they
are coming together the set in this in
the same speed of the state space and
we're getting these kind of things
they're all moving together so there is
definitely some motions in my direction
but this is I think probably a good
month of me playing around with this
kind network before I'm going to get
something that's going to be like ready
to use but I did start I did try and
make a few prediction to this to see how
it works and so I picked a random
collection of images right and random
few predictions and some and something
that really really nicely so about half
of them actually if you set kind of it's
quite a type threshold about half the
map really nicely and so you get like
really so different images and like
these are different colors i should say
i can see all my they are definitely
different colors so you get quite
similar and these actually have a slight
different patent but they come up as
they come up as being two pockets but
the downside of this is I'm still
finding it's picking up kind of
collections of things that I mean these
aren't the same right I should say so at
the top of the bottom of the ones let's
switch to the same they're just not the
same so it's it's this is all work in
progress right this is still definitely
getting there but i think that takeaways
for me like the things that I definitely
learn concluded from having gone through
this process is that there's the kind of
a few things and neural networks are I
know they're known to be able describe
arbitrarily complex much
and this is true you can do amazing
things with them but the problem is they
will exploit any issues with your data
it will exploit any errors any artifacts
they will work around and learn in new
ways that you didn't think of that might
not actually be useful to you so they're
quite they're like yeah it's like trying
to teach a really intelligent child that
doesn't really want to do what you want
it's going to do whatever it feels like
so more data can be very effective and
those Julian's talk you know we throw
lots of data classification problems and
the more users you put in the better
your results I'll it does work really
well but when you're trying to get your
model working it's tempting to think
that the problem is that you haven't put
enough data in and that's where it's
going wrong and what that means is that
every time you make a decision you then
spend six hours waiting for the results
to come out only to go oh it's still
broken and then you can lose a lot of
time just continuously thinking that oh
it's just if only have any more data it
would generalize it would it seems like
an easy kind of pitfall to have when
when it's known that the lots of data is
good but I think simplifying cases where
you just have one or two points when
things you can really understand what's
going on and when it doesn't work you
can follow the maths is really really
useful no no it can be difficult to
interpret I mean we've seen so that you
know there's lots of ways of visualizing
your networks there's lots of ways of
looking at their tuition two layers and
as you can you can look for which parts
of the images are receiving attention
from images and you can there's a lot of
things you can do this more and more
increasing ways of visualizing networks
coming out but there's still known to be
very black box they're still hard to
know what they're going to do what pay
via still haven't in a given case and
today are a very tricky model to use but
I think people use this as an excuse to
then just kind of not do this just to
simply assume that it's okay to not
understand the network and then to kind
of focus on other aspects of the problem
but I think if you're going to use
something that's more complex and more
difficult to understand then you need to
work harder to understand what it's
actually doing and you need to simplify
the problem make sure you understand
what it is and then build up more slowly
otherwise you can just as I did you get
yourself in
very like tricky scenarios where you
just have too many moving parts and you
don't know which piece a job but most of
all it was very good fun it was really
entertaining to this you know I've
learned a lot about machine other
machine learning algorithms and this to
me was like an entirely new kind of area
to research so I say if anybody is
interested playing the stuff it is
fantastic fun so please don't let me
discourage you thank you very nice talk
thank you thanks um you didn't really
talk anything or didn't talk about
regularization at all can you say a few
words on that whether you found it
useful or how you used it yeah I can and
I didn't do that much welcome
organization I took too much not some
regulation here because for me the lot
of the problems I had in getting this
working came down to you in
understanding that the network can
describe what you're doing and but I
think you're right regulation is
extremely important lot increasing the
size of the image data set certainly can
help and being able to get to the point
where regulation is effective you know
effectively sold that kind of training
test problem is really useful and so all
the time I've been doing any of these
things I always run train and test at
same time and for the small data sets
you very quickly do hit that point where
they diverge very very horribly I've
played around with things like drop out
this uses actually the network on
relying on underneath has bashed
normalization which is a very effective
from vocalization and it means that my
input representation is already
extremely stable to a lot of variations
in the images and so it's not it wasn't
a sensitive in this case but I think
what we're this is likely to go is we
want to take the multitask problem that
we've done for classification gender and
color and I want to retrain this I want
to add this as a task so we pass the
images through and then we we passed two
different images through or tossed
Ribbit's through and then we do all the
different classifications and we do the
metric planning and that should
hopefully mean that we can find out this
is a dress and this is also a dress and
are they the same or not
and that kind of thing I think we get
that I know you have we spoken about
kind of the nature of most organizations
I think yeah it's definitely way to go
hi your algorithm was about classifying
duplicate images but your problem is do
products yes have you got to the stage
where you are saying this these two
products have like a certain number of
duplicate images in common or how you're
going to deal with that so the reason
for approaching the problem on image
basis is if you clean your data set up
and you're left with no and you're left
in the position where all you know that
yes you have a set of images that are
all from the same product your army
labels left it's kind of hard to
separate the set of images and do
something with that so the idea is this
is to take the simplest unit you can
work with which is we know these are all
pictures of the same product so let's
see whether you can take up any two
images from a product and determine they
are from that same product once we have
a stable space for working in and we
want to then look at using a lot
independent ensembles of those images to
say that given a collection of just one
you can identify it's an image and
actually have the network do the
averaging on that basis but they'll
probably a step in the middle what we do
try the kind of collaborative approach
where we say yeah that's good
so before neural networks came along
people approached very similar problems
using shape descriptors in pattern
recognition and in fact there are there
is quite a rich body of research
starting with with with image moments
and all kinds of sophistication on and
forward about shape descriptors so I
wonder if you'd add some shape
descriptors to the images maybe the
neural network would be given the right
hint it needs to learn the right
features yeah I think that's a really
good point and we actually have an
existing product duplicate candidate
suggestion like service in production
that relies on brisk features which are
kind of like sift features there are
similar so we we use this and it works
in certain cases and there are there are
certain class of images that are really
good it's you know which is really good
candidates for but there's lots of
classes that it's very very bad at so
yes I think that's a really good idea
and I think we could definitely
concatenate our deep representation with
the brisk representations and use that
combined thing to learn digital section
yeah definitely
concerning the different perspectives of
the same object in principle isn't not
very different from algorithm to
constructing panoramas from picture do
you think there can be some
collaborations of this kind of
algorithms and and then classification
by your nest started at crane so in
principle reconstructing understanding
that several pictures of a show from
different angles is a single object is
not too different from building
panoramas from pictures and then
obviously understanding whether it works
or not yes yeah let's a good point and
some of the other papers which are again
which I haven't cited here and talk
around trying to map so they're usually
the researcher and this is our own face
detection and they talk around trying to
map faces onto a 3d object and use that
but those papers were super like the
results of those papers have been
substantially beaten by just training
networks given a variety different
images and just minimizing the ability
to distinguish they all the same so
there have been approaches around that
and I think that's what stimulated a lot
of the research into this but it's the
triplet loss and the contrasted loss of
both and have had results that have
beaten moral complex more kind of
special approach to the moment and
training in this way is quite easy to
set up i think i need about 25 lines of
code to do the contrast of loss training
without any like without people you need
in the cross-validation all those things
whereas I think the more of those that
kind of problem is I think harder to
pose so I think it think it's
interesting our research and it may yet
be that that is there all the more kind
of firm successful but it's yeah it's
harder I think to approach it
any other questions thank you